hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book 10 of the Republic Plato is
providing us with an argument why we
should distrust the poets and their
products dramatic epic lyric poetry you
might say the cultural producers and why
is this he's made several other
arguments and then at a certain point in
the discussion he makes one that has to
do with the parts of the human soul he's
talked about this earlier in the
Republic beginning in particular in book
2 but then discussing it in much more
detail in part 4 and the Platonic
conception of the soul or if you prefer
personality is that there's really three
main parts to it one is the rational
part the low geek' and in greek the the
part of us that engages in activities
like reasoning measuring numbering
weighing calculating this extends not
only to what we might call speculative
or pure reasoning to use a term that
became quite popular in the modern
period but also even more importantly to
practical reasoning thinking about how
we ought to behave what is good and what
is bad and why it's good or bad and if
we have conflicts between more than one
good how to work out those conflicts how
to arrange goods in a sort of hierarchy
or rank ordering all of these matters
fall under practical reasonings and
that's part of the activity of the
rational part this is also the part of
us that has curiosity about the nature
of the cosmos and how everything works
and and uses our our reason or intellect
to try to understand these matters Plato
thinks that every human being has this
although in many of us it may be short
circuited may be underdeveloped it may
be brought in only to be used by the
other part
it may be under utilized so this is a
very important part of us this is the
best part Plato says the highest part
it's the part that ought to be running
the show there are two other parts to
the human soul the spirited or sometimes
translated as passionate part this is
the part with which we get angry it's
the part that's concerned about honor or
social status and approval the Greek
word for this is - most it is the part
of us that gets riled up and it's a
middle part it's it's it's not quite at
the level of the other desires and
appetites and it has a certain dignity a
certain value to it but it's not the
same as the rational part it's not as
good and then we have the appetite of
part this is the lower base or part of
our human nature driven for desires for
physical pleasures such as those of
eating drinking and being intoxicated
having sex all of those sorts of things
it's also the part of us that gets
driven to try to acquire as much money
as possible why because money is an
instrument by which we can actually
indulge those pleasures money is not
pleasant in and of itself I mean if you
do find money Pleasant and you're
passing up other pleasures you've really
got your priorities mixed up as far as
Plato is concerned but even if you're
just saying I just wanted a good time
that is merely indulging the lowest part
of yourself and so all three of these
parts are important and Plato says that
they have different roles and each of
them has its own way of thinking about
things each of them has its own distinct
pleasures so there's a pleasure in
reasoning there's a pleasure in social
status there's also physical pleasures
in eating drinking having sex laying
around all these other indulgent matters
so what is the importance of this in
terms of poetry Plato says let's think
about matters
that can appear different to us like the
stick going into the water
we know that the stick is not bent but
if we trust that only our eyes if we
trusted the realm of sense then we would
say that the stick is bent when it's in
the water and it's not bent when we take
it out there's a kind of contradiction
there or at least conflict between the
two different appearances however if
we're reasoning or if we're actually
using you know Plato really likes these
mathematical things of measuring
numbering and weighing or if we're
engaged in calculation then we can tell
ourselves the stick is not bent
similarly to use another example the Sun
is not about this big it's gigantic
but our senses can't tell us that our
senses can only tell us what they
perceive and our senses are quite often
wrong about that we can say similar
things with our emotions and many of our
desires that they they are contradictory
they don't remain constant
they give us mixed messages you can say
so Plato says different parts of the
soul do different things now here's the
fundamental question which parts of the
soul does mimetic production imitation
poetry the other arts what is it that
they appeal to well you know if we think
about visual arts it's very easy to say
that they they appeal to this lower part
of us they're not engaged in calculation
as a matter of fact they can depict
things to us as very different than they
are right think about painting and the
effects that you can produce by
monkeying around with perspective right
Photoshop now is a way in which we can
do that as well or think about the
effects that you can get with different
lighting think about what you can do in
movies or other narratives with the
soundtrack now
when you're doing that are you appealing
to the rational part or are you
appealing to these other parts Plato
would say you're tapping into these
other parts of the soul and he has a
criterion that he brings up here that's
quite important he says it's impossible
for the same thing at one time to hold
contradictory opinions about the same
thing so a human being can hold
contradictory opinions how is that the
case well our rational part tells us one
thing and then our spirited or appetite
apart tells us another thing we can just
say higher and lower parts as Plato does
here poetry tells us the messages about
things and their appearances that
appeals to the lower parts so he's got a
very interesting metaphor here he says
mimetic poetry imitates human beings
right and we can go on and on with this
and he says that mimetic art is an
inferior thing cohabitating with an
inferior what does the inferior the
lower part of the soul and engendering
inferior offspring so artwork poetry
music all of these things that are
essentially not philosophy or not
science or not something that's real
based on actual knowledge and engaging
our intellectual part is all within this
realm and is continually generating new
illusions new slights of hand new forms
of to bring up another art jugglery
right that that he's talking about so he
gives you an example and besides the The
Crooked Stick this is a very interesting
example that he uses so when we feel
grief or sadness what is going on he
says is a man in all of these sorts of
things when they feel things of one mind
with himself or is there facts
and strife do they hold contradictory
opinions about the same things at the
same time is there a division within the
human being him or herself so what's an
example of this he says when a good and
reasonable person experiences a stroke
of fortune like the loss of a child how
should we in fact take that well we have
different options one is we can lose
ourselves in grief and say this is the
worst thing that could possibly happen
to me and that is in fact what this part
of the soul is going to suggest and
that's what the imitative arts are going
to depict think about paintings doing
that movie scenes think about all these
dramatic scenes within Homer's Iliad and
Odyssey one of the things by the way
that I actually like about Homer's work
is that he's perfectly willing to follow
the cultural norms of his own time and
to show grown men tough men crying over
the loss of their comrades
whereas we often give the message you
shouldn't cry right you should have this
toughness instead big guys don't cry was
the model when I was growing up both of
them would be both of those points of
view actually would both fall into this
lower category however they can be in
contradiction with each other because
they're both wrong from Plato's
perspective why because if we're
thinking about things rationally
we don't actually know enough about life
he says to be so absolutely convinced
that dying young is a terrible thing and
he also says the law and and moral norms
suggest to us that we should remain self
controlled that's different by the way
than the toughness that's that's you
know stuffing everything down and prison
proof you know Privett preventing us
from from showing our emotions by hiding
them so he says that the parts of the
soul that are actually going to be
better for us to follow
they're not engaged by imitative poetry
so this has some very important
implications that we can then explore
you